a las vegas woman is hoping the
community can help search for her
service animal now typically we talk
about dogs but that is not the case
we're talking about her tortoise that's
right it went missing on saturday august
13th from her home near edna and lindell
right by roundy elementary and policy
park jeremy j ford reports
a little over a week ago this porch gate
was left open and a loving tortoise made
his way out into the community and now
the owner needs the public's help in
finding him i wasn't always like this
but you know it's a tortoise so i can
keep up
kimberly blowers is talking about her
tortoise
she has multiple sclerosis and must use
a wheelchair to get around and watson is
her service animal he's like my little
man and we rescued him
last year she has given him a great home
but earlier this month that all changed
when she says the mail carrier left the
gate open and watson got out it's just
been
lonely neighbor donald somerville says
he only had the chance to meet watson
once he knocked on my door
and asked me if i had seen the tortoise
and i said no they were looking for it
and i thought well maybe somebody
stopped and picked it up blowers took to
social media and set up a gofundme in an
effort to raise a 650 dollar reward for
the return of watson i just want
what jeremy j ford 8 news now
jeremy thank you for that well blower
says in the past week more than 17
tortoises have been found but none of
them were watson watson is microchip so
anyone who finds a tortoise can have him
scanned by a veterinarian or reach out
to kimberly blowers on facebook